the system
what's up bro
hey what up Brent oh I gotta hang out
what's going on I got a honey holes I
have a whole thing of chicken broth that
I'm gonna drink it sounds really sick
well I am so excited but it's in my nose
and it's been getting worse and worse
you know what but it doesn't stop what's
going on there so that shows but you
also have that new whatever the
Southwest strain is you have it I had a
strong nose cold and that's never going
to stop me because my body feels good my
body feels strong that nose even catch
them my nose has got some problems
anyway
um here so here's the other thing about
you and me we get in here and we do a
podcast And when everybody else is on
vacation
true yeah now what I like the rest of my
shows are taking time off but this one
can't stop won't stop
um I like to what I really love to do is
take a plane to Philly
spend time with my wonderful in-laws who
I do love and and then get back on the
planet for three days come back to LA
and then leave tomorrow lead to the
place yeah
yeah nothing beats up like fun there's
nothing nothing in time we're going to
realize nothing is worse for your body
than playing
yes we did cause we back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
first of all we're both wearing very uh
environmentally friendly colors and that
is not by design that just happened
actually I was thinking I'm gonna go
green and you went I'm gonna go green
I'm gonna go green green on green but
this shirt was made in the coal mines in
the Congo that's well it's made of
cobalt thread
and there's and that's how it is if you
own an electric car or a cell phone
um by the way uh and I do both of those
uh my cell phone and my car was made
possible by the slave labor everyone's
with did you watch that guy on Rogan
yeah but I've been following that way
before that oh way are you still bought
a Tesla yeah but you bad guy I mean
because if I would have known that you
know I mean I've hated electric cars
from the job well I had from the jump I
hit I had how can you still subscribe to
these the movement of electric cars when
you know subscribe subscribe when you
know there's mothers with babies on
their back that are again deformities
the pollution the the toxins they're
inhaling the whole thing's a disaster
okay so anybody who thinks that you know
driving an electric car is actually
green that's adorable well no you're
worse when you buy your [ __ ] Tesla
we've talked about this by the time I
got in my Tesla it was I I didn't
realize this but I was already I had
already created 55 000 miles of
pollution that an F-150 would do because
when you make that lithium ion battery
in China you do it on a cold grid hey
yeah I think it's time
apologize
because I come here my V8 naturally
aspirated V8 or my twin turbo V6 flat
inline six Porsche you're always like yo
you the environment the environment oh
look at me have a Tesla I'm so much
better than you remember those days yes
and by those days I mean last three
years yeah well what I do what I do is I
go like oh say sorry I go like this well
hold on I go better over there than here
and that's not right because I'm not
being a good Global citizen but I'm
going to yell every morning you're
killing baby I liked it but I'd like to
I'd like to quote who is the who's Kevin
Costner playing Yellowstone uh John
Dutton I'd like to quote John you'll
watch that show so don't quote it like
well I've been watching that show I'd
like to go like Julius Caesar when all
these Chinese tourists are out of their
bus and they're too close to a grizzly
bear he says you got to get in your
truck somebody's going to get eaten are
you crazy she says it doesn't seem he
seems friendly and he says I promise
he's not he says and he says look you
see all this land that fence and that
fence I own all that land that way and
she says they don't believe you nobody
should own all that land and anybody who
does should share it she says to the
Chinese in Chinese you translate and he
pulls out a shotgun
and they run away
and then he shoots it again and as the
Chinese patriarch is getting under the
barbed wire
oh you're responsible for covet no he
goes he looks at him and goes this is
America
we don't share land
I was like wait what's that have to do
with electric cars I'm just saying I
like to quote Americans have a different
way of looking at things
oh hell yeah dude I like that full
circle I think uh yeah we have a
definitely a a different way of looking
at things we also pick and choose what
could cause a a muck about because those
people those social justice Wars
whatever like fighting for whatever it's
like but you're tweeting it from your
iPhone or Android which is horrible or
comes from horrible things well Peter
Zion said he's a global strategy said
you know we're doing well when people
are fretting over pronouns yeah if
pronons are actually something you're
thinking about you have it so good it's
unbelievable Eric Griffin has such a
good bit on this they had to fall last
night at the Laugh Factory
dude his bit on this on pronouns and so
in like customer service is so good it's
so good I'm not gonna get it's so good
he had another it's so funny dude yeah I
was laughing so I was in the back
cackling yeah I was like could you hear
me he's like you were I was like a dude
I'm sweating he had I saw him too I saw
him bit itself remembering it now oh
it's so God it's so funny I wish I could
say it yeah me too I wish I'd written it
it's one of those jokes you're like oh
no
yeah he's one of the good ones yeah I
was doing sets with him last night
Russell Peters I haven't seen him
forever another great and then when I
get him on the podcast he's so down yeah
uh he him and I live close to each other
but he uh Russell and I were talking
last night and he was saying that uh
there's the boys yeah Jeff Garland my
boy
yeah Jeff Garland so great but uh
Russell and I you know he's a he's a
he's a Gearhead he's a car guy so we
would always talk about cars it was so I
haven't seen him all through the
pandemic he was torn like we were you
know all through the pandemic I'm like
yeah I'm seeing him we bumped on tours
first I've seen in years give him a big
hug I'm like talk to me what cars have
you gotten he's like you're gonna hate
me like what he's like dude through the
pandemic I realized like what am I doing
he said I got older I got married quit
messing around I get serious sold my
house moved a new house I downsized he's
like in all those cars he's like I have
it all I only have two cars and I went
oh wow
okay we have nothing to talk about so
I'll see you later he said I just
he's in pandemic man you realize like do
I need all these cars I was like right
right I said now um did you get coveted
he was yeah I don't yeah do you think
this is like one of those like side
effect things where you just all of a
sudden now you just stalled her become a
bush how old is how old is Russell 50
yeah
talk to me in 10 years Bubba I know I
know already I'm I'm getting worse about
40. no you're still 39. yeah you're
still in your 30s yeah amazing one I'm
holding on dude March March I turned 40
though [ __ ] dude
what do you do for 40 what are we gonna
do freaking wait huh probably getting
some weight I don't know in my face just
my face your face is mighty swollen
four double doubles last night oh my God
that's a lot so you Dre you did a lot of
drinking did you eat a pizza or
something what did you no I'm on
Carnivore I started carnivore uh
Christmas night so what's that how many
days okay well you eat some fiber or do
something because your body well it's
the alcohol oh okay you can't drink that
much and then not get sleep and expect
you and wake up looking like Celine oh
you can get much sleep either no no
because I you know I went to bed I got
home at one my kid's working at six oh
that's a problem oh dude it is so you're
really sleeping four hours yeah it's
whatever
um right I ride hard but um dude and I I
text you this yeah
I am
this is an understatement I am okay okay
hold on no no it's gonna make me mad
because I know what you're going to say
I am it's so annoying I am balls deep
into fish right yeah I know you are a
fish tank he bites fish aquarium and now
he goes I get this text I get this
[ __ ] textbook I'm gonna read this
text wait let me give you let me give
you the audience context go ahead so my
son uh when I was a kid I had all the
animals obsessed with fish fish tanks
learned in and outs of fish I had fish
books you name a fish your boy has owned
it then you get older you're busy go to
college you can't get in the fish tank
you have money so it's kind of expensive
I haven't been into it in at least
probably 20 years fish fish yeah and
then my son his dad I'd like a fish tank
I'm like well I know about fish I'll get
you a fish tank I go to Petco I get a
whatever 20 gallon tank I'm like that's
big enough for him that'd be cool I'm at
Petco and I'm looking through the fish
I'm like all these fish are kind of lame
dude so I'm talking this
brilliant younger Mexican gentleman and
he knows fish experts oh dude look up
look up what a fish what a fish obsessed
person is or an expert I was just going
to show you a picture of my face but um
Pasco Mania so yeah I'm pescatarian
Pennsylvania so
uh it's your thoughts which is like an
expert at fish but let's see what yeah
that's what I am I'm an egthologist
well I am but so I'm talking to him
right and I'm like man these fish are
kind of lame when I was a kid there's so
many more options and stuff I was like I
don't want to get my son these stupid
fish it looks around us all right dude
the fish here suck he goes you don't
know where I get my fish ears where he
goes rainbow so uh uh Ventura down the
way there past 405. it's called rainbow
aquarium they have all the fish ask them
to see the fish in the back like
don't give don't give all the stuff away
say last no it's all legal okay I'd go
in there bro it's Ace Ventura's house
Pet Detective you can get everything I
get this from excuse me Brian I bought
tiger a fish tank and now I'm obsessed
with fish tanks I want to spend all my
money on a saltwater tank and buy
dangerous fish all I write is Brendan
please
he goes nah
um fish boy now respect it I go just
settle for one tank man nope
I need danger fish
I go
okay as long as you don't get a
stonefish lionfish or piranhas it's fine
we'll get you a couple Sand Sharks Sand
Sharks sand sharks are fine he goes nah
need lionfish feed me lionfish yelling
and I go no they sting he goes yes
I'm like dude dude so Brad you know Sean
our boy Brogan used to have I talked to
Rogan he had piranhas piranhas and then
he had this section called death row and
it was just goldfish so I I didn't end
up uh buying the scorpion fish because I
talked to the the fish guys like you
have kids man let's not do that right
but also the salt water which I'm uh
gravitating towards in the near future
when I turned four down that's why I'm
gonna get myself as a big [ __ ] put in
my living room uh octopus careful yeah
steel fish yes oh see I like that yeah
so when I went to the store because my
son it's a freshwater tank dude they're
you know when I was getting the
freshwater fish were kind of [ __ ] like
goldfish betas whatever you know yuppies
or whatever yeah all that [ __ ] fish
not anymore daddy Oscars gangster uh uh
chichelys or chichles gangster really
Jack Jack Dempsey fish so probably
they're probably from Asia somewhere
some of those Asians Asia Indonesia do
in Mexico dude so I got two Jack
Dempsey's so we bought the the whatever
the the the liberal fish from Petco
cichlid right cichlid yeah how about uh
so so I buy the you know the common
average fish for kids yep
I'm looking at the tank I'm like God
these things suck dude and so I go I'm
like let's and tell you it's seven
o'clock tigers in his pajamas and it's
bothering me all night I'm like
I look up that secret fish store down in
Ventura
close that eight seven fifteen I call
him we go you guys opening it was for
next 45 minutes I go I'll be there in
20. I shave tiger you wanna go see some
cool fish he's like it's late I'm like
let's go see some cool fish drive down
there I'm talking to guy I cover type of
videos I'm like can I get these [ __ ]
fish right now like we have freshwater I
think you get like some I want some I
cover my sons a year oh yeah I'm like
ear muffs I don't like these [ __ ] fish
hey I don't like these [ __ ] fish if
they happen to get you know [ __ ] up
that's fine do you have like some more
aggressive like freshwater fishios do we
ever show us those chicken Lids showed
me the Oscars show me I got so now I
have I have two parrot fish super
aggressive I have uh parrotfish yeah
yeah bring those up they're cool no I
know parrotfish I have two parrot fish I
have uh a Jack Dempsey which is a
chiclet aggressive chicken Jack Dempsey
Jack Dempsey Jack Dempsey chocolate of a
Jack Dempsey I have three lobsters you
have three lobsters one blue one orange
you have three one red those are not
freshwater oh yeah yeah freshwater
lobsters dude that's that's Jack Dempsey
there I have a straight up Lobster daddy
three of them one blue one orange okay
so now if you go fresh if you go and
also have an eel you have any heel of an
eel you have a freshwater reel I'm an
eel where's that from I don't know
Amazon or something really
don't get an electric kill I'm begging
you don't get it oh no I don't want that
I want to get shocked now hold on but
now here's the problem yeah so I have
Jumanji going on in this 20 gallon tank
that Jack Dempsey fish they're like oh
he's gonna get to play a foot big dude
and the two pair of Fisher can get
bigger too and that eel and the lobsters
they're all options
well they're not on each other because
those Petco sheep fish are in there
so the the boys ganged up they ain't got
much space
they ain't got long to live when are you
and those kind of fish you have to feed
other fish no oh you can feed them no as
long as they're in similar size like
they don't all have to be the exact same
size but as long as they're not small
yeah if they can't fit in their mouth
they don't they don't like the parrot
and the Jack Dempsey and the eel and the
lobsters don't mess with each other
there's respect it's like prison yeah I
create race Wars inside the yeah yeah
lobsters you guys hang out there yeah
Jack Dempsey fish you hang out here para
fish you you're over here they all
ignore each other do their own thing
they did fight early on to establish
territory which I enjoyed me and tiger
watch with popcorn he fought they fought
they fought boom boom boom boom boom
boom
the parrot fish which we named Big Daddy
because he runs things he's smaller than
Jack Dempsey he runs some [ __ ] threw the
fin down
he threw the fin down he established
order it's his house cleaned his house
up and his little girl let me ask you a
question what about piranhas can you
bring any piranhas into the mix you know
I'm glad you asked I looked it up they
do have problems no no you can get them
get him you can get them you can get
them because they're different kinds of
piranhas there's different kinds and
they're not and they're not what you
think no people think that you drop them
they don't do that at all no at all they
got teeth now the big pajamas
have you seen piranhas bring up some of
the bigger piranhas and I want to sell
they're not going to kill a human if you
jumped in a a large school of piranhas
they're not going to eat you alive
they're probably scared and run off now
a barracuda a barracuda rip your wieners
are are no joke now those teeth look
like they would hurt like a [ __ ]
that's a piranha right there okay that
might be that might be Photoshop no
that's a big that's a real piranha Bubba
that's what their teeth are like don't
know the teeth are like that the piranha
is probably not that big look you don't
see his hands there it's a 50 that's a
Photoshop record that's Photoshop
but you can buy products now there's a
fish called a aqua Aquafina or some [ __ ]
like that uh uh a silver Aquafina bring
that by the way my friends even laughing
and how bad you are with names the worst
you were talking about niedermeier which
is Neymar Neymar and you were talking
about all and you said all of them are
on the same team yes they were like
that's not true they were laughing so
hard my brother-in-law and my love
soccer they're huge soccer cleansing
like dude they were laughing so hard
they actually made the rounds on Tick
Tock good that's arowana the arowana
dude so you I go there um tigers that
thing was cool I'm like is it aggressive
the guy goes
listen you can only have him what do you
mean he goes now he's this big right now
he'll get a foot or two foot big and you
need 155 150 gallon tank oh so he's
eating it oh my God they get so big
you have to feed them ready what you
feed them 10 crickets a day [ __ ] off I
was like oh not not for me no Caillou
goes Dad let's get that one not for me
buddy oh and here's the other thing you
have to have a special lid because they
like to jump and they don't realize that
there's no water on that side they will
burst through the plastic cover you have
and jump out of the tank no they're not
gonna hurt you but they're so aggressive
can't have that they're so aggressive no
you can't have that now am I leaving
here to take my I think it's either 20
or 30 gallon tank and am I buying a
hundred gallon tank today have I already
put it on purchase yes you're buying 100
gallon tank show me how big a 100 gallon
tank is please
look if you guys like creativity and
productivity it's about it's about
increasing the brain's release of alpha
waves all right oh you're talking about
that nootropic everybody talking about
talking about Alpha Brain now I use the
Black Label Alpha Brain that thing will
have you design a spaceship tomorrow I
haven't tried that yet you'll start
doing some things you've never done
before I've heard I started doing I've
heard now I Engineer for the city of
California tell me about it tell me
about Black Label that's it you take it
and you're you're basically Jeff Bezos
yep it's like you just start figuring
stuff out I mean if you look at the
people that actually take it that swear
by it I was very impressed you got some
high uh Nancy Pelosi Pelosi's not
getting carried away let's not get
carried away but uh Alpha Brain is the
top seller it's been they've sold over a
million bottles the people that created
it that started on it's still taking it
really uh the listeners know this I'm
very sensitive to caffeine I don't drink
tons of okay is it caffeine free uh you
know it is but you drink a lot of
caffeine but I know that's that's the
joke promotes cognitive functions
including memory mental speed and focus
and it it it helps you zero an uncomplex
tasks and you get this confidence you're
not going to get that that uh that
jittery Fury no it's not as far from
that it also uh on it so confident in
the nootropic Alpha Brain if you don't
like it the refund your money keep the
bottle no return necessary all right so
save temps off your order by going to
audit.com
f-a-t-k save temp stuff not only Alpha
Brain but the entire site workout Gear
streaming Fitness kettlebell steel Club
maces protein powder Warrior bars
everything everything all right so get
you some onit.com
f-a-t-k now are you gonna are you gonna
go salt water right away or you wait
until you're 40. I'm waiting I'm waiting
I've never known you to wait and when
March I turned 40 in March
right now this is for time this will go
in his room got me a couple months a
couple months couple months three months
and then we're going we're going Sizzler
with with oh we're getting real lobsters
we're getting octopus we're getting
puffer fish you're getting an octopus I
don't have to really oh they're cool so
you're getting an octopus oh yeah do you
know what kind you don't know you
haven't done the research yet you got to
be careful though because if you get an
octopus it might clean your whole
[ __ ] tank out
they're very smart circle of life
now octopus might be too young hey what
if Daddy got him he's too smart what if
Daddy got a squid
Little Squid Ink yeah squid would be
good but you don't want your your you
don't want anything getting all Inky
this is 120. that's the closest one
that's 120 yeah gallon tank in reference
to a person you gotta you probably have
to get something that big right for the
salt water yeah right
if you want to get the bigger fish you
have to like I love Oscars and they need
to be in 100 gallon freshwater tank
because they get so big if you're
getting salt water you might have to go
220. that's a lot that's so much money
so they're so expensive how much are
they I mean dude you can spend you can
spend what what can you you can get
crazy can't you I've already gotten
crazy it might it might and my wife was
like hey you're this isn't good lesson
for Tiger 250 pounds
well no that's for the tank that's just
for the tank yeah
so total about you're looking at four
grand
and that's not including the fish but
you know what I will say this when you
see a beautiful nothing better display
nothing better it it brings your
cortisol levels down when you see fish
swimming around in slow motion dude
especially their cool looking fish oh
dude me and tiger I'm we've had the tank
for four days uh we'll stir it for now
it's the only thing that calms them down
otherwise he's bounced off the walls
hooked on there some sharks sorry I
speak French sharks there's no cool
sharks what well if you wanna you have
to go get some black tip you'd have to
go salt water yes maybe that's all you
can have no you can't mix any other
fishing with them yeah you can no no no
not with Sharkies really like legit
Sharkies no that's the thing with those
chick lays it like cichlid you have to
be careful what you mix them with right
because they kill each other they'll
fight each other you got to be careful
and then you're just wasting it so you
can't have a shark it's fascinating
because originally the guy was like you
can't have parrot fish and a Jack
Dempsey then I went online they're like
you actually can as long as it's not a
male female pair with a male uh chick
lay then you got a problem
see that I like her and I like that
aquarium I like the whole set of fish
too now you see you guys see the Sharks
and you got some fish in there that's a
stupid uh leopard she's beautiful yeah
she's cool yeah
chose to take me see you got the you got
them sharks you might want to have just
a tank with sharks and whatever else
and I like a good puffer fish now
they're very aggressive and the puffer
they have legit spiky bugs [ __ ] you up
my problem is you're telling me you
can't have something like that just and
what happens is is that a stingray chin
yeah you can do that you can go shark
and Stingray aquarium but you see how
basic it is you can't have a bunch of
stuff we're getting something when you
have guests you can go the feeding
begins at four everyone the feeding and
then you [ __ ] drop no I don't even
tell them I just get a bell note it's
dinner radio not for you yes not for you
the feet everyone gather around you hire
me to go the feelings beginning in five
minutes everyone five minutes
feed him daddy
chicken soup is making for hot excuse me
taking the cream of the frog off yeah
dude yeah I'm obsessed with tanks right
now man I can't get enough so relaxing
and all the I like the the mess the
different fish one's aggressive one's
not you gotta pair them up right what's
going on with your dog
you know
yeah
dogs are dogs man dogs they're a lot
harder in some ways than aquariums
what's the maintenance on this see that
thing when I was a kid I was a bit of a
beast now the the the filters and the
heater stuff are so Advanced good health
man it's all about the field you don't
want you buy the kit because it comes
with like the cheapest filter you got it
you gotta accessorize you gotta yeah the
lights is all about the light the if
their lights are too bright and they're
on all the time the fish get aggravated
that's when they start killing each
other so you gotta you gotta tone down
the lights they have LEDs now you can
change it from Blue to purple to red and
it will change the the environment for
the fish so they're a little more calm
and when when you feed them you can make
it real bite now right now I feed the uh
Jack Dempsey and the parrot fish and the
eel and the lobsters I feed them uh uh
blood worms Frozen blood waves toss that
in these boys go wild the thing about
having a girl's Dragon my son had a
beard dragon the problem with that is
that you got to keep uh crickets and
they stink like the worst [ __ ] in the
world and you got these blood worms yeah
yeah I have that Frozen blood worms a
little packet there boy that and that
eel man I didn't think he was gonna do
well at first but he is really
flourishing he's really come out of his
hole Yeah he eats oh it is fun to watch
good good good well guys this is
It's been a fish hour with
eschatologists I'm an eth katologist I'm
an if technologist
dude chin are you official Christmas
Brennan
are you a fish guy I feel like she
didn't be a fish tank guy I was huge in
a fish I used to catch fish remember I
still love fishing
in Murder there's killer no we know you
like to murder him I'm talking about
like the appreciate us
oh [ __ ] so I had large enough bass I had
panfish I had a bluegill and would you
eat them something no I'm a little
hungry I just learned about him I would
feed him stuff see how they would if
with crickets I would put him in there
and you see this crickets they're
studying your prey you're studying your
friends yeah it was fun good see I feel
like that's worse because you're taking
a fish that's in the wild and then
locking them up these these fish they
don't yeah but when you're in Illinois
you're gonna die sooner or later you
know being a fish is like you're always
gonna have a hard time you know
but I tell you when I was in Tahiti and
I was snorkeling in that Lagoon
oh you saw some [ __ ] octopus schools of
fish see you can bring that to your
house I know why not the maintenance is
no pump now section it would be worth
the four grand I was talking about fish
and he was like yeah because I was like
yeah piranhas right and I sent pictures
I was like check out this Jack Dempsey's
like oh that's sick he's like the
maintenance killed me though I was like
well you must have had a long time ago
with the advancement of Technology the
filter and stuff you don't need to have
something come to your house all the
time now if you can do salt water you
probably should have an expert set up
the because the ph and the the salt you
got it a little tricky but you just you
have someone set that up but then once
it's set up you're good dude really with
the the technology and the filter the
filtration system the heaters you're
good but how do you and the live coral
and all that keep it all they have a
whole process that runs runs all that
and the lighting is key now it's so much
fun dude obsessed I'll just stare at
them well you know the next level of
wealth if you ever get to this point is
you want to have a bunch of little
miniature horses the way Schwarzenegger
does in this house he just has miniature
horses well Rob Dyrdek was the first to
do that he had the mini horse yeah it's
like invite him and big black just yeah
they try to ride it would bite him oh
and bite him all the time yeah
[Music]
yeah they were the first ones to do it
oh my Lord shut up mini horse ah the
horse is too much work these fish are
pretty easy once you get it going like
it's a little work in the beginning yeah
you set everything up make sure they
don't die right
it's always you still got to do the
thing where you take because from the
store they give you the bag of water you
set it in your current tank for 30
minutes and then release them oh you do
because of the temperature yeah
otherwise they get you know like shock
from it because the new environment but
they not but even then when we were kids
you had to I think we have to wait 45
minutes an hour now they have liquid you
put in there that makes them chill out
and not have like anxiety yeah so you
put the water the the drops in there
it's all sized oh dude it's come so much
further well because you have people
that are obsessed and they figure this
stuff out dude can't get enough you
didn't wish me a merry Christmas on
Christmas I didn't get a text from you
people are listening to the Pod because
none of my friends text me Merry
Christmas like they're listening yeah
because everybody knows unless your
close family don't text me on holidays
yeah yeah it's gonna be a good gear shut
it
shut it yeah Happy Thanksgiving I know
dude yeah you know we assume this we're
friends you get an emoji of a turkey oh
good good Christmas though in Philly
he's not good at the Christmas thing is
it a winner Christmas
yeah I I uh
it was Winter Christmas it was so cold
that their dog my my wife's family's dog
went outside and went I'm not going for
a walk today yeah I love that one dogs
do that hung out it was like no no [ __ ]
in the house
now was it so cold in Philly they
stopped shooting each other
was that that cold or not yeah I don't
know outskirts she lives actually in in
Jersey in the suburbs oh so now in a
town
wear houses and they have the plaques
were made in 1780 oh they're haunted
they're haunted they're the oldest in
the world yeah yeah so it's nice yeah
that sounds nice to put a little
Christmas up here they take it seriously
my family my my wife's family you come
down you will be given pajamas the men
will wear I like that matching I mean
men wear matching women wear matching
the kids wear matching everybody has
their own I mean that's what we do too I
come down with my baby 11 months old my
mother-in-law
she goes you go upstairs right now and
get uh you you gotta go put them in his
outfit ah I woke up I didn't see it it
was laid out right on my back ready to
go yeah man I like that tradition I like
that too we do the same seriously we do
the same then we play board get we play
board games kids open up their toys
tiger guy I got one that he thinks from
Santa's [ __ ] ass but I got one of those
Oculus the meta Oculus the the virtual
reality things have you ever done that
no it's insane that's how you know I'm
getting older I get sick doing it dude I
get sick dude because the the depth
perception I don't know if the
technology advanced I did this too I got
sick with the virtual reality because
tiger will box and you're you're it's
two minute rounds like real boxing he'll
do
12 fights 12 times that kids score a
goal yes it's right there what a stud
oh no
that was that won the game yeah
look at your T ran away
oh kids tackling
he doesn't really like soccer though his
coach texts me uh this yesterday was
like hey just want to make sure you know
it's filling up uh he wants to save a
spot for Tiger for the spring the
Tiger's like that I don't like soccer
yeah I like football he's gonna be
killing you can do it all dude that'll
help you get ready for football but he's
just not feeling it even though he
scored I mean that's a good way to end
your career as a soccer player game
winning goal during the World Series of
the and then summer the little Winter
Camp celebrating everybody jumping yeah
he loved that how about that video legit
video that's not that's not me yelling
that's another dad I know yeah I don't
sound like that I would have been
cussing and yeah
saying something probably vocal [ __ ]
yeah yeah you don't like soccer he's
your kids your kids get everything on
their Christmas list because I feel like
my kids basically did no I don't play
that because my kids if you give them
too many gifts they don't appreciate it
and then they'll move on so they're like
all right you didn't appreciate this
gift it's not as cool as this gift I get
him what my dad did with me you get one
good gift yeah and that's it dude
my daughter would ask for she's asking
for books
a new tennis could you post more uh
wedding picks please I enjoy those
because you post more of those how many
have I posted that's the only one I've
done not often yeah
look at how old I am get my [ __ ] oval
face out of here loose Invisalign I
don't care get my face it's not working
what happened to my face
Jesus Christ I can't even talk about
this I didn't take those pictures yeah
I'm you know me I'm not a Sentimental
guy I'm the worst
anyway
all right another [ __ ]
I'm terrible with that stuff you showed
me old school picture you're a little
cutie pie when you're about my age
you're definitely better looking than me
when you're my age
I was 40. I'm trying to enjoy ideas very
slowly
well you know that's the bad thing use
your jaw you lose a lot of [ __ ] hey you
look similar you just you you lost your
hair
now man nothing to do about that that's
father talk well yeah he's your Barber
yeah he's everybody's Barber he's just
cutting yours faster everybody's
everybody's Barber you're just cutting
yours it might be time to get on the old
tea I'm getting oh you're so full of
[ __ ] I'm getting all my levels you've
been saying this for how many years I'm
getting my levels checked they're doing
[ __ ] bro as we get older it's important
you do that that remind dude how about
uh we I think we text about it me and
Rogue we're talking about this morning
how about Steph and Bonner passed away
uh what a bummer I saw him with the last
time I saw Rogue and I saw Bonner Bonner
came to Rogan's uh show in Austin uh in
in Utah and I noticed and I want to be
respectful of course but I noticed he
was very very skinny very really yeah I
didn't I didn't recognize I mean like
half of what he was yeah I think you
know I knew he was struggling with I
guess opioid addiction and I I don't
know if it was addiction you know I know
he had some issues and you know the
police guy called his house and also the
poor guy's house burnt down
South burnt down uh why didn't you tell
me my Invisalign was wasn't in I have
one more month and I like it when you
don't wear them I have one no I don't
want it to work out for you no I don't
want you I have one more month I can't I
don't want you have better teeth I can't
wait for you to have to go under the old
that's gonna happen when I'm your age uh
but yeah with with uh Bonner and I I saw
uh he was I did so here that's a good
point so Sean Strickland brought this up
and this is how I felt too
so Sean Strickland goes listen man I see
all these people posting these tribute
stuff in Bonner and like oh I miss him I
can't believe this happened he's like
where were you guys when he needed you
where were you when he's going through
the tough times his house got burnt down
he's clearly having some substance
issues where were the pictures then
where was the reach out then he passed
his way everyone's like oh my God this
is horrible check me out here's me and
Stefan Bonner I've pictured me and
Stefan I'm not posting that I wasn't
that cool now I support him from the
outside like I sent him money was house
burnt down I would shoot him tax I'm not
posting a picture when he passes away
who's that for so when John Strickland
doesn't you know Sean says I appreciate
that about so Sean goes stuff upon her
just died and my Instagram feed Google
uh is flooded with pictures of people
like hey this is me and Stefan Bonner
training we're buddies we used to hang
out back in the day I'm gonna post a
picture about him and get double tap
likes he's right Strickland said in the
video but like man the stuff in Bonner I
knew was [ __ ] nuts he was addicted
opioids he got arrested got kicked out
of the hospital because they won't give
him opioids uh his gym went under during
covid you know me I'm an [ __ ] I'm not
gonna go post a picture like rest in
peace I'm an [ __ ] uh you freaking
people that like after he died he post
pictures of him in support of all this
like when this man was losing his [ __ ]
that's why I agree 100 when we're doing
[ __ ] where were you I'm not saying you
had to be there for him but you weren't
there for him then don't be there for
him now when because he doesn't need it
I think it's a great I think me too it's
like hold on when he was here struggling
that's a great point he was struggling
very openly on social media that
everybody beloveds all the listeners
that you guys love social media and all
the haters love social media where was
this same energy when the guy actually
could have used some [ __ ] help yeah
yeah a lot of people don't realize about
Brendan chop is that he he uh he helps a
lot of people quietly you've sent a lot
of money to a lot of people yeah but I'm
like I'm not gonna get on social media
like oh Bonner I hate to see you leave
man I didn't know you enjoyed the money
I didn't know he was struggling yeah
everyone anybody in the community knew
he was struggling was it opioids I I
don't know to to be honest I know that's
what Strickland said maybe he knew him
better than I did I'm not sure what do
you I know I know he's having some
issues he's a good guy I worked with
Steve he's always a nice guy to me yeah
I did it I worked with him uh me and
Adam Carolla and him did something I got
to know him then spent the day with him
and then uh you know and had seen him
periodically he's a really good guys we
had this uh we had this casting I forget
for what show it was made for EU I
forget what it was and we're all you
know casting I was there sitting no
there's something else okay did I bring
you in on the Adam Carolla thing no when
Stephen was there no okay so we're all
we're we're all sitting in the waiting
room ready to you know do our thing and
there's like all these guys we all look
at the same everyone looks like Aaron
Hernandez some variation and then Stefan
Bonner walks in and I go bother because
you know the UFC alumni so when I see
someone it's like oh [ __ ] what's up dude
finally it's like we see another comic
in a party like oh thank God yeah people
suck so I see him like oh dude what's up
he goes not much man turns around here
where are you going
if you're doing this I'm [ __ ] out of
here
and I was like well I thought I was like
I was like wait what I thought maybe you
didn't like me no you're gonna [ __ ]
get it I'm out of here I was like oh
dude no not this that's not you have no
idea what they're gonna want in there
yeah he's like you think I'm like I know
dude I'm not a sh [ __ ] chewing I
didn't get it either like what are you
doing no no what are you doing I mean he
didn't get it either so I mean probably
both should have walked out but it's not
the right attitude uh yeah yeah I didn't
know I'm that great we've had some
Runnings and he was cool yeah you know
he but he was going through it very
openly on social media and posting
social media and Claire was having
issues and how many of you people that
posted a picture did a single thing for
him but then when he passed away keep
that same energy
don't post because you know you feel
like you have to or you think oh no I
did the show 10 years ago with Bonnie I
can't believe this happened no no you
knew the guy was in the dumps dude he
just didn't do [ __ ] for him and then now
because what you want sympathy for who
Bonner he don't he's gone you're right
who's at four why are you doing this I
think people feel like they they need to
pay a tribute it's a bummer to them you
know so sometimes just pay the tribute
when the guy could actually use your
help yeah like now all of a sudden I
can't believe it yeah well but you
believe in you we all saw it unfold on
social media him freaking out in the
hospital because the opioids aware of
the [ __ ] his pill addiction was did you
reach out then now some people think I'm
talking about just in general some
people actually did try and help him
reach out the majority did nothing yeah
sometimes you sometimes though in in to
play Devil's Advocate and I I agree with
Sean Strickland in spirit but you know
sometimes when people are in the
Whirlwind of that stuff it's it's
basically impossible to help them isn't
it it's really there's nothing you can
do and money might go the last thing it
goes a long way to reach out
it does if you cared about that much you
could at least check in on it yeah yeah
not wait till the guy passes away yeah
and they go oh my God I can't believe it
what can't you believe yeah that's why
I'm not I'm with Strickland did he oh
dear his heart just stopped they said he
was at work and had a heart issue and
then passed away all we know is it's
heart complications this family's not
releasing any yeah
[Music]
so many people were texting me like the
media does not report this but you know
and I'm not gonna say what they told me
he was doing you know he was doing bop
bop bop I'm like no I know I knew he's
having issues he's either way he was a
good complicated great guy yeah [ __ ]
good guy and then then the MMA Outlets
are like tribute to a warrior to a
legend wow interesting because you
haven't talked about him since he made
the headlines for well that's their job
too it's not though no no no hold on you
want to give him a tribute no no
journalist no so so the only time you've
ever gave him his credit was when he
passed away
and then before that the only time you
highlighted Stefan Bonners when he was
having an outrage at a hospital what
would you say what would you want him to
say I mean he died he's an MMA he is a
he is a Pioneer to an extent so but but
Griffin was iconic sure sure you give
him you give him that you sure you
realize that you want his family and his
closest friends would want that so
should we only highlight if he was still
alive should you only highlight his
downfalls
because because we only appreciate
people and once they pass away people
only become Legends once they pass away
I don't know I don't subscribe to the
social media and the the media Outlets
where negativity is what gets clicked so
that's what they're gonna do right
because you could appreciate Seth and
bottom being this Legend help them out
and highlight that yeah there's an
anniversary every year every year so if
most of the news and if for 10 years
most of the news is you
having a run-in was something or someone
that's going to make the news it's it
comes with the territory of being a
public figure right
and then when he dies they're going to
say we can talk about that but he kind
of put himself in the news with that
behavior
right yeah my only thing is is like all
right so you're gonna Glory glorify and
say how great he is when he passed away
but before your ticket yeah
giving a tribute to a guy who was iconic
right or or had some iconic moment I
don't have an issue though I'm saying do
it while he's alive just don't do it
when somebody pass away don't just do
clickbait I don't know what if they
didn't do that Bubba like I don't know
it's my world but I mean they didn't
appreciate Stefan Bonner when he was
alive
it's the same people posting these
tributes I don't know I mean you're
putting the press in a kind of a tough
position here because you're going to
report on what happened right well no
you should definitely report on their
death yeah you're gonna report also on
on when they're in a fight in the
hospital or they're on opioids whatever
it is and I'm that's fine do that but
also highlight what he did well
don't just make it this negative
storyline until we die unfortunately it
clicks her that's the but see that's the
problem that's my problem with it with
everybody like you're only going to post
about this guy when he does something
negative yeah and passed away it's like
oh but he's this great guy it's like you
hold on a few months ago you didn't have
the same energy now he's this great guy
yeah I don't know it'll never change I
mean that that's comes with it won't
change because people are it's Marilyn
Monroe I mean that's the song Candle in
the Wind that's exactly what [ __ ] uh
uh what's his name Elton John wrote
about it's like goodbye Norma Jean it's
like they never knew you at all you know
it's like
they just said that was that for Prince
Diana no that was for Marilyn Monroe oh
was that Mary her name was Norma Jean oh
well yeah bring up the lyrics and it's
really cool because he said he said um
like for him he was a gay man so he saw
her as the woman who goodbye Norma Jean
though I never knew you at all you had
the grace to hold yourself while those
around you crawled they crawled out of
the woodwork and they whispered into
your brain that sets you on a treadmill
and they made you change your name and
it seems to me you lived your life like
a Candle in the Wind never knowing who
to cling to when the rain set in and I
would have liked to know you but I was
just a kid your candle burned out long
before your Legend never did and
loneliness was tough the toughest role
you ever played Hollywood created a
superstar but pain was the price you
paid when you died even when you died oh
the Press still hounded you and all the
papers had to say was that Maryland was
found in the nude right and it seems to
me you live your life like a Candle in
the Wind never knowing who to cling to
in the rain said and I would have liked
to know you but I was just a kid your
candle burned out long long before your
Legend ever did so goodbye Norma Jean
though I never knew you at all and it's
good same thing but oh no goodbye Norma
Jean from the young man in the 22nd row
who sees you as something more than
sexual more than just our Marilyn Monroe
powerful yeah
he's saying that when he sang that live
when Princess Diana died at her wedding
oh I mean our funeral I remember that
like it was yesterday because my mom
could not stop crying she loved Elton
John could not that's a great song oh my
God I didn't realize that for some
reason that's why I associate with
Prince Diana because he sung it live
that's why you hear that like he he
could he had Bernie talpin Bernie Temple
was The Lyricist they could write some
songs back yeah it's like that that uh
that guy from the three Migos who died
not offset the other one uh Three Amigos
yeah it's called Migos but yeah
Three Amigos but Migos that band
remember the takeoff take off passed
away he was on a podcast it might have
been drinking Champs or drinking Bros
whatever he was on it weeks prior
people are asking because the other two
I think once his uncle wants his nephew
or cousin but the other two are more
famous and I apparently he was kind of
like the a lot of the brains behind the
operation and they asked somebody and he
goes people want to acknowledge my
greatness till I'm dead here's that's
the way it works in in music and
entertainment yeah when you die they go
hold on ain't that funny oh no he was
actually really talented and he goes
they're not gonna appreciate I pass away
fast forward two weeks later passes away
oh my God they're never gonna be the
same the band hold on because you'll
have to comment three weeks ago before
he died saying he wasn't [ __ ] and he's
leave the band they need to fire him
yeah and that same person's like oh my
God the band never be the same you
[ __ ] idiot yep yep
yep
it's a bummer
um that's why you gotta get it's kind of
the way I double down on fish dude there
are a lot of [ __ ] great artists that
were never discovered until after they
died Van Gogh being the most famous
example but there are a lot of them
Andrew Wyeth
you know found his they found his
[ __ ] paintings in the Attic
awesome you know you twirl away the
whole point of as you get older for real
is like if you're toiling away
you know
for a result
it's very easy
to re you have to understand that that's
not the point you want to toil away for
its own sake
because you may not get it you know and
and that's okay too because there's a
great deal of value in the reach and
more importantly also you know just be
in service like if you can if you can
change your mindset to think I'm I'm
here to be of service in one way or
another even with my art even with my
expression I'm just here to make people
laugh and change maybe the way they
think whatever it is that will take a
lot of pressure off you and you'll put
most of your attention on the fact that
you are a vessel of service you're not a
vessel of consumption you know it's not
about you you're children of God the
great ones right no yeah but the great
children the great the great architects
of the Middle Ages they made these
incredible structures incredible
paintings they didn't sign them no you
didn't it wasn't because they weren't it
wasn't about them yeah it was about they
were building it for something
of course yeah but they didn't yeah I
know now you would never see a great
house before he passed away but he was
doing it with drinking Champs said of
course so this guy goes grocery shining
before but you were dancing on this one
it was your time it was always your time
to prove it is that something you had in
your mind when you were going to the
recording uh Noriega asked and he put oh
for sure enough is enough I'm chill I'm
laid back but it's time to give me my
flowers you know what I mean meaning
it's time to acknowledge my talent I
don't want them later on when I ain't
here wow two weeks later dead
horrible
so give people their flowers when
they're alive man yes and that's why I
want ten roses who said that before Oh
for you Christopher Hitchens said that
they said he was dying of throat cancer
and they said what would you what do you
regret he goes I regret not calling the
people my colleagues and telling them
how much I like their work yeah
I get it
yeah it's a bummer
yeah but rest in peace stuff and Bonner
was a legend the UFC wouldn't be what it
is today if you do and remember when he
lost that fight on The Ultimate Fighter
one to force Griffin remember it was on
Spike at the time
I think Force won the first round Stefan
won the second round the third round was
razor close could have went either way
crazy and they gave to four synopsy
Force had a different career path than
Stefan so you know it worked out but you
know if bottom would won that fight who
knows you know it's just it's
interesting man crazy fight and force is
beloved and obviously Bonner went down a
different route but just isn't it weird
must be weird for Forest yes I'm pretty
sure Bonner named his son griffin based
on first Griffin really I think [ __ ] I
didn't know I didn't know Bonner had
kids
uh wife and kid yes
there it is Bubba uh named after a force
Griffin uh
um yes so that's a bummer although named
after first yeah
well uh yeah they got married in Italy
wow
they have one son wow
cool name Griffin yeah great name yeah
um was I gonna tell you so it's a bummer
what was I gonna say
about
Forest
I don't remember Boris Boris Griffin oh
dude how about my papa's coming into
town he flew he always Fly Southwest
drives me nuts cancel flight well they
canceled it and they're like we're not
doing any flights to early January like
they can't every all flights to Burbank
La yeah and that's flying to Burbank and
then they so he canceled it and then I
was like oh Dad I'll just find you
another ticket I go online and Delta and
United are like say last we're the only
one you can fly now minimum ticket 1800
bucks oh 2100 you 12 hour wait like you
gotta stop in Salt Lake City eight hours
what so then my dad was like it's just
on the cars they'll come out you know in
January I'd rather drive than last night
late at night he got an email from
Southwest we're back your flight's on
time so he's coming out tomorrow oh nice
weird right dude I tried same thing I
tried to buy a ticket I was like let me
see if I want to change my ticket mail
just buy a new one yeah from Philly to
L.A no no yeah you enjoy that
yeah
that's still more than 2 700 flights in
the account said it's because they don't
have the staff the staff in the weather
it was like yeah they always say weather
yeah but it's the code they don't have
the employees when they mandated mandate
uh
mandated yeah
one was benefits for him yeah so when
they did the whole vaccine requirement
thing a lot of people quit or you know
so they'd have the staff
well all Airlines dealed with that
because they all kind of played by those
same rules you know it's just Southwest
is massive massive
damn dude
some of that stuff sucks when you've got
to get there nothing worse that's why
John Candy drove uh one of the great
movies one of the greatest movies
Planes Trains and Automobiles nothing
I'm talking about but I also like that
movie I'm talking about home alone [ __ ]
home alone because John Candy they're in
the airport and he's with his band and
he goes well we're driving to Chicago we
can take you Macaulay Culkin's box
that's right so then she jumped in the
break but with with Steve Martin trying
to get home for Thanksgiving
when John Candy's sitting in the uh
train station
and he says uh
and he's like he it just makes sense he
goes and he realizes that his wife that
he keeps talking about died a long time
ago
my favorite John Candy movies uh Uncle
Buck
great movie hilarious how's your
plumbing I've been eating a lot of
cheese
why is he John Candy one of the great
[ __ ] actors North Star right oh wow
he's everybody's North Star that's what
she's asking he's like a bigger guy and
I think John Kennedy's Canadian too yeah
you gotta understand I as a sketch guy
from Mad TV my my director was his
director my director came from Second
City yeah so here comes [ __ ] oh Brian
Callan at 27. no experience a complete
[ __ ] idiot with John Blanchard who
directed all the sctvs Jesus Christ so
he had stories about Martin Short and
[ __ ] John Candy and all those
[ __ ] Catherine O'Hara he was
the director and he was like their age
this radical Canadian [ __ ] and
John Candy came in the next season and
he goes I've been studying Benny Hill
all summer Benny Hill was a great fat uh
English comedian he had a sketch show
[ __ ] hilarious he goes it's all about
the wig you gotta have your wig just a
little too small
so every character every character you
see him is his wig is literally [ __ ]
this big it makes no sense he's got a
tiny wig he's like what's going on
[ __ ] he was [ __ ] bring how old was
he when he died when uh John Candy hell
dude have you studied Benny Hill as a
comic Bubba you got a YouTube Benny Hill
you gotta YouTube that [ __ ]
he was so funny dude
he was so stupid John Candy was probably
40s 40s right I think he was 37th he
might have been no shocked it might
shock you watch this because I know my
shot Chris Farley's death
holy [ __ ] wow he was so great
he just couldn't lose weight he would
hire some John Legend died in Mexico
yeah while filming wagons East John told
me he would he would hire
um a trainer to finally hey go to how
much did John Candy weigh when he died
under there a lot
he would hire
um a trainer Bubba and then six two
that's not terrible he'd hire a trainer
and and John would be in there with his
trainer after like a day it'd be like
Jonah come in and John and instead of
working out he'd be there with a scotch
with his parents like what's up now we
were just talking you know some days you
got to take off it's like it never
worked never man 43 and he's only two
275 pounds at six two yeah that's a
lifetime especially compared to a
lifetime of smoking and drinking and
[ __ ] obviously I think how old was
Chris Farley I won't say Chris Rice is
like my age when he passed away no Chris
was really younger Chris was 36 that's
who I was thinking about
33. oh my God the thing how much work he
had left he was just killing his genius
oh yeah just getting stuck that is such
a bummer but he liked his blow
um cocaine and morphine can't do cocaine
anymore commonly known as a speedball
can't do it who is his hero pollution
exactly how blue she died exactly
there's someone exactly the hotel Alpha
Sunset which I can't say the name of
such a bummer I remember this so well I
was with Phil Hartman the late Phil
Hartman well the sunset well the the
bummer too about the Belushi passed away
you know Robin Williams is in there
Robert De Niro was in his room that
night
because he had one of those chateaus and
he had one though like Lofts and they
all came in there it's horrible look at
those young guys
oh my dude look at the talent in that
picture
and right if you're just like Chris
listening this uh on audio it's a
picture of a Young Adam Sandler and a
horrible outfit which I kind of
appreciate David Spade uh Chris Rock
with a mustache and then Farley with a
handlebar mustache if barley was just as
fat he's as fat he's as wide as the
three of those guys put together well
and I took a picture last night with our
boy Russell Peters and I look just like
that so that's cool but um I'm heading
down that route but I'm definitely
holding 33. you're you're much you're
very handsome in that picture actually
what do you think yeah my hair was on
point that night I I like when Chad
Hanks and his buddy were looking at you
and they were like
God you're [ __ ] huge and that guy had
no idea you fought in the UFC and he's
like he's big I go yeah oh he was like
do you ever want to do Sports and then
you were like I was like this yeah yeah
yeah
you did no research before he came in
here top 10 in the UFC he goes he so he
could kick some ass I go he beat up
anybody you know and he goes maybe you
should play football I was like can you
leave
can you just get out of your whole life
with sports
until he was 30.
it's hilarious yeah what can you do
let's get some current events Jen come
on come on I got a fish tank to attend
to that's what happened what are you
doing for Years buddy watching my fish
I'll be in buying new fish you're not
you're not doing a set I refused it well
I might do a set in town in L.A okay
Laugh Factory just hit me up literally
before we started the show to do a set
with them I think Theo might be I think
lap Baltimore I sold out we're sold out
Thursday I think we're about to be sold
out Friday you know I listen you're
you're gonna do great and you're a
veteran for me when I would do news it
was just I think the move is to do a
nine one nine o'clock show on Saturday
before the ball drops doing the late
show and counting down on stage
everyone's on their phone they're
talking they're drunk they just wanna
I've done it every I've done it every
year for 15 years and you're right I've
done the last six years and and I
remember I got an offer to do it this
year my brother's on the email and he
goes remember he goes you're you always
say yes he was remember last year the
minute you got off stage you said I'm
never working New Year's again it was
stick to that dude he's like every year
for the last five six years you've
regretted it he's like just stick it's
not a big deal Stu the next week right I
was like you're right I absolutely hate
it that's fine now in town it's gonna be
fun if I do one spot to laugh with you I
can get back on the road sleep in my bed
it'll be great San Diego Mike drop
comedy club though January five six and
seven tickets are actually moving there
too so let's go and then I got Fort
Wayne Indiana January 13th 2017. looks
just like stranger things it does just
like all right then I got Danny of
Florida January 1921 I got a busy
January and then we got Zanies in
Nashville yeah
I'm taking Feb off it'll be good for you
although I'm at the comic strip February
February 23. no that's just one weekend
yeah but still yeah uh we we just
announced a new tour date we got two in
January the first stop for the 2023 uh
tour the Ohi fake tour whole new hour
January 5th through the 7th that's next
Thursday Friday Saturday the Wise Guys
in Vegas to kick off the new tour for
next year for this coming year and then
end of uh January Tampa Florida Tampa
Improv January 20th through 21st then
February we're in Springfield Naples
Bakersfield so your boys working I like
about it I'm proud of you some fun ones
good stuff
yeah Las Vegas would be fun all right
let's go
all right first one is Samuel Jackson I
guess his birthday was just recently
like this is Brian callish it when you
don't know what you're doing on Twitter
74 years old I guess he liked a lot of
hardcore porn didn't realize it was a
public thing I don't care why this is a
thing it's not even we can't pretend
people aren't don't like that 74 can he
not live his life but he's he he removed
all the likes after he found out people
were telling him like Hey like hey
they're like you know this is public
yeah nothing is better now this is a bit
of a hiccup nothing's better when
somebody you think you're bad at social
media when Troy Aikman thought D that
thought he was dming didn't understand
DMS and was flying into LA to work for
like Fox to a big game and he dm'd like
one of his side pieces just some vulgar
[ __ ] everyone's like uh hey Troy Troy we
can all read this
[ __ ] he's like oh [ __ ] God yeah I think
he was married at the time right and
then yeah yeah well someone but hey mate
letting you know your lights are public
you want to see them someone goes can we
dead ass see we can dead ass see your
likes they're public big bro God bless
you this is funny too
Samuel
it's a meme with uh you're like a
republic Samuel I love it yeah I love it
all right well there you go but people
had to decide they're also saying like
hey man let him do his thing who cares
if he wants can you not celebrate on his
birthday and like a little bit so you
can watch hardcore porn on Twitter I
heard there's a I don't know personally
but I heard there's a bunch of porn
there's like only fans though I don't
know Elon took over I don't know what
what he's done on there but so you'd go
to Twitter and watch so you know
Instagram you can't have any like no
like real nudity but apparently uh
Twitter you can so yeah yeah no
Instagram YouTube you can't have any
nudity or opinions is that doesn't align
with them and then it's a joke and then
uh Twitter's kind of free for all right
now okay but Twitter just so you guys
know Twitter this is updated uh someone
sent me this update who uh used to work
for Twitter Twitter you can't uh like if
you post a link to like I know an
Instagram post or to Facebook or to
another platform they'll take your stuff
down but you can do a link to your tour
dates or a show or you know but if you
post another social media platform I
don't think YouTube's including that
right now but other ones they're gonna
flag you and you'll get a strike which
listen if I own a company I get it yeah
if if I own Ford yeah I don't tag Dodge
in your post
that's all
uh Samuel liking porn makes me like him
even more but I apparently he likes
anime porn he said he said in an
interview like yeah publicly yeah he
likes Hentai Hentai which is I think is
the octopus octopus with like wieners
yeah I do not understand it God bless
people it was their work around I guess
you can't have porn so that's that was
their workaround in Japan you know he
was a cracker he was in the depths of
hell yeah who what Samuel Jackson was a
crack addict
you know Morgan Freeman used to bag
groceries I was working with a guy at
Albert's when I was 16 I was a janitor
at a grocery store in Albertsons in
Greenwood Village Colorado and this guy
was trying to be an actor and I was like
oh and Denver's gonna be tough and he
goes Morgan Freeman bad Groceries on it
no no I get that yeah I get it he used
to work at a grocery store not this one
but uh he's the exception right I'm not
saying you can't do it I'm saying saying
Morgan Freeman used to you know Morgan
Freeman also breathes air too I mean
that's hard hard cases don't make good
laws yeah I mean people I remember Arena
Football I I hate my life I'm like this
this is not what I forgot you played
Arena yeah
uh uh I was like full back and then but
I originally brought me in as a receiver
and I was too big and there's no tight
end so like we're making more before no
side ends and then when we get to 300
pounds that was the plan so I started
eating a lot a lot you know me I already
have body issues I hated it and I was
like how much am I getting paid they
told me and then I went to the captain
of the team he was this great dude like
six kids and I was like hey hey man if
you don't mind me asking you're like the
start of the team how much you make him
he told me I was like uh bro I can make
more at Starbucks yeah it was Diego
anyways For the Love of the Game I get
that you do this full time on that
salary oh no I work for UPS full-time on
it and he just you get done dropping off
packages and come to practice he goes
yeah I went bro this is the idea so you
can make into the pros because Kurt
Warner did it once there you go so a lot
of those because I was like what do we
do literally I was like what are we
doing same as UFC I'm like what are we
doing yeah how's this end for all of us
they're in the locker I'm like what are
we doing and then they'd go dude Kurt
Warren described him like one guy no I'd
go no I know no you took her one of the
MVPs I get that that's one out of how
many of us
but again you don't want to base things
in decisions based off hard cases make
bad laws but also you're not going to
achieve any greatness basing off odds if
someone like if your dad was like if
you're a kid I don't be an actor
comedian and he goes you know the odds
are one in 10 million I go okay well
that doesn't work for me for me it's
whether it's whatever it is University
of Colorado Football hey you know the
chance of you playing in Chicago one in
a million or you being a headline comic
how about my Dad's friend my dad my
Dad's friend said that to me he goes you
want to be an actor you know you have a
better chance probably of being a
senator because I imagine you want to be
a movie star I guess so because like Tom
Hanks said I never gotta go I I guess so
he goes you got a better chance of being
a senator you know that right are you
willing to take those odds I was like
see I don't like those see I don't I
don't like odds I don't get my son on no
I know and now
now to say you can be anything you want
to be that's not true no but even if you
because if you're colorblind or you have
some issues with your vision or you need
Lasik it can be uh in you know the Air
Force you can't be a pilot
NASA a chance to become president not
great but hey shoot for it I don't do
the odds things with Mike I'm running
for president
sure eventually yeah do your thing dude
David Ortiz yeah so I just saw this came
out today today the guy that shot him
remember he was yeah yeah was it in
Brazil I forgot
Republic
so he got he got uh he got a shot he's
he's only getting 30 years in prison
it's a lot of time but Dad trust me I
guess he can't dealt with David Ortiz is
uh well the skull and black panther
tattoo definitely is a giveaway but
here's the thing David Ortiz is like Tom
Hanks in America
imagine if someone [ __ ] with Tom Hanks
yeah people are gonna come for him if he
is so beloved in the Dr and in Boston
you say a bad thing about David Ortiz
you're in trouble now you try and kill
him and they you they put a face to it
trust me I highly doubt he lasts 30
years wherever he's at look at it if he
were to get out early he's [ __ ] nine
others were also ordered to spend time
Behind Bars due to their alleged roles
in the shooting including 28 year old
Alberto Miguel who prosecutors had paid
those who carried out the ACT that's 20
years it still it seems like so little
years for attempted murder you know
Watch What Happens yeah watch what
happens to those boys David Ortiz a is
connected B is so beloved why somebody's
killing him was he banging no I heard it
was it was a uh the wrong target mix-up
yeah something had happened they're
gonna get there I don't know because
he's a mastermind on the attack Victor
Hugo Gomez Velasquez have more names by
the way he was acquitted Victor Hugo as
Vasquez
no this was a whole four names
hold on
his liver and small and large intestine
were damaged by the bullet
wow and the guy even threw this wait go
up chin it says authorities only said
they did not believe Big Papi was the
intended target of the attack instead
revealing they believed a man named
Sixto David Fernandez hell yeah these
names was the man the shooter wanted
alleged because he once ratted out a
drug Runner to the cops so yeah I've
always heard he wasn't meant to be but
I'm telling you messed with David Ortiz
the Dr yeah you can get dealt with is
that him right there that's the the guy
that that's accused or now he's damn he
doesn't look like things
he wasn't the person I was meant to
shoot it was someone else uh that's what
he's saying but Dave Ortiz connections
go okay I know okay where are you at we
know exactly oh we have friends in that
prison
it's not good can you play that and then
no no no no no we don't need to play no
I'm not doing let's try it we're gonna
try it let's try this picture you know
what is him talking in Spanish which we
don't speak yeah and it's going to
demonstrate
this sucks so Javonte he's had issues
with a closed hand okay that doesn't
make sense that's called yeah that
doesn't make sense
nah it's a punch I don't know so
apparently the woman had an abrasion on
the inside lip the the cop said now I
have I got skeptical hippo eyes Javonte
Davis hits Knox grown men out maybe
maybe
trust me I'll let you know who should
die for he ain't one of them yeah so
he's done this before yeah he's His Own
Worst Enemy dude I want to see him
fighting Ryan Garcia's yeah I know he's
supposed to fight one other person and
he's supposed to write one and then Ryan
but now his fight's like in January 7 or
like soon
he's so dumb dumb dumb dumb hit a woman
what happened here well we don't know
what actually happened no he was
arrested there was enough proof to to
show that he did he might have done
something so okay so he hit her on the
side of the head what I was trying to
say is that if they knocked out he if he
hits you you know with a close with a
fist you're going to [ __ ] sleep okay
B how do you know she didn't I don't I
don't you we have no idea I'm telling
you this ain't the guy to
um
yeah
my problem with him is he's actually you
know I've worked with him before yeah
yeah because Showtime guy he's a good
person he comes from the absolute
gutters of Baltimore and he still
engulfed in that environment even though
he's made out and he's such a talent to
me he's the most exciting guy to watch
he's the best knockout artists we have
but Deontay Wilder's argument there he's
even better smaller he knocks dudes the
[ __ ] oh yeah must see TV show time
started him from the bottom now he's
here nothing nothing but he's still in
that world yeah you know it's the most
violent world in the world Baltimore is
worse than anybody yeah the wire the
wires the watered downwards unbelievable
so for him it's just such a shame
because like dude you're about to be the
face of boxing your must-see TV yeah and
you're [ __ ] yourself what was that
Denzel Washington said to uh Will Smith
oh I didn't know you like the Devils the
devil's the Devil comes to you at the
high at your highest point you know my
problem is he's not in a size Point yeah
your highest point he was just getting
started you have the the Devin Haney's
you have the the uh the Ryan Garcia
how's he do against all his guys knocks
him out
he beats Haney to me is the most
talented guy his jab he's not the most
exciting so he won't might not get the
same star power Kevin he's not smaller
it feels not as strong actually no no
Technic technical wise his jazz is the
best I've seen and I don't know how long
really so talented but he's not Javonte
Davis will knock your [ __ ] head off
Ryan Garcia Town's kid I think July
Haney might beat him via decision if you
don't get knocked out he's so talented
but as far as Javonte Davis when you
know that Denzel Washington line they
put out
he's like like he's getting there he
just became a pay-per-view star he
started you know 500 000 papers pretty
[ __ ] good in boxing yeah better in
Deonte Wilder did in his last one been a
lot of guys so he's up there especially
for a smaller guy hell yeah you're just
reaching the kind of the Pinnacle you're
still out there
and you do this he'll pay he'll pay
he'll pay her off
something will happen boxing's you know
notoriously known for sweeping under the
rug and stuff like that and especially
he's the star so I you know I wish him
the best but if he did actually hit a
girl with a close fist I can't support
you anymore
dumbass it's such a bummer but we don't
allegedly allegedly allegedly
all right um some of these are from also
cut your hair huh right don't have
pigtails
how tall is he
tiny Davis
if this says five five he's five three
on a good day damn I couldn't believe
how small he was damn and the calm tank
hits like eight now that's what's insane
truck Daddy yeah must see TV still five
five
if that dude if that
all right Garcia 511. that's tough to be
that small now when you're that talented
especially that weight class
is an advantage for him with his
leverage and his ability to hit like
that
it's uh it's such a bummer this bumped
me out all day
yeah the Bonner stuff bummed me out then
this I saw I woke up to this I'm like
from Luke Thomas he was like this ain't
good and he works for Showtime I'm like
oh your boy Luke yeah tall lacrosse
player no Luke Thomas
[ __ ] you you don't know Luke Thomas
bring him up Modern Combat oh I know
he's like the face yeah with a beard
yeah he's like the best of mind and MMA
you keep in touch with him oh yeah
that's my guy yeah as far as like legit
journalist goes he's a good guy that's
my guy I like him very much yeah I don't
there's nobody better but I think he's
uh no his his show more in combat with
Brian Campbell just won uh MMA twice or
something show of the year like two
times at least they started the show
time yeah I'm the one who vouched for
Luke to come fella look at him next to
him oh Luke's huge he was a marine
Luke's no punk a [ __ ] man is girls
dwarfing Rogan there how tall is he he's
my height he's very big remember we went
we reported a podcast in Vegas are you
sure he's [ __ ] like he he looks like
he just won Joe in a carnival he's giant
no he's my size maybe an inch taller and
then he especially he's getting shape
too like he's he's the giant man get
over her size though but he uh his mind
is what's Giant yeah but like I didn't
realize he was that big I don't know who
cares a journalist though I do yeah wait
so he was a marine he never fought no
he's a Marine but my first like big
fight out of Colorado was in this W
something uh WC or whatever and he was
the commentator
so me and have known each other for
about 20 years 15 years at least and we
had to sit down with them for the
interviews I've always been a fan of his
and he was like yeah I've been funny man
come up through Colorado I'm like really
he was like the first guy who paid
attention to me wow and he goes so where
do you go from here remember this is my
second fight ever against Johnny Curtis
or third fight ever he's ready to go
from here like man I'd love to get my
hands on a Frank Mayer Josh Barnett he
goes oh wow
because I'm not gonna write that but wow
you saw I'm not gonna write that yeah
because I'm not gonna write that but I
appreciate your confidence okay yeah
great guy great how do you get into
fighting he just I don't know he's just
a mastermind of it dude he had a show
for a little bit on ESPN like he's
finally getting this dude you know he's
like there you know there's some guys
who get a lot of shine nobody has been
in Luke Thomas yeah as far as breakdowns
covering the sport he's the best we have
he's he's our who's Big you know like
Stephen A Smith is Big you got Skip
Bayless big he's just like those guys in
MMA he's always the guy he's not
controversial like he's not gonna do
things he's not gonna do like he's gonna
do the clickbaity stuff real Journal
she's not gonna argue with Fighters you
know because he does none of that stuff
he doesn't want to be involved in that
yeah what else you got Jen alrighty
let's go here
so apparently there was a 60-foot albino
python that was in Texas uh some guy had
in his trunk it was in his car someone
stole the whatever bag they had
I know right but it was lost it was no
one could find it it was 16. people
would see sightings of it somehow that
see that's where it would be scary like
if there was a 16 foot python loose
around mine they were biking and you
you're down that path and you're like
what the [ __ ] I seen that picture that
during the middle of the pandemic is the
summer when I ran in my first
rattlesnake and it was a anaconda it was
an anaconda with a rattler I was like oh
my God that has to be some sort of world
record I posted it to my Instagram and
cam Haines was like dude that's the
biggest rattle I've ever seen I'm like
right I don't know what to compare to
it's a [ __ ] dirt serpent I don't know
what to do with this thing oh I ran the
other way and then it's a Viper I stayed
at the top of the hill and I warned
every rattlesnake down there it'll bite
you and you will be and then this guy
comes gangster you know he has the boots
on [ __ ] look like crocodile hunter of
Calabasas I'm like dude there's around
so you just show me gets out this huge
knife I'm like whoa dude you're in his
territory be quiet no no there's kids
and dogs you can't have that man you'll
show me we go down I'm like it was it
was just right here dude
see ya
I ran home
run home you gotta run ran them not me I
Charmed the snake you kill him I tried
this thing I always carry a small but so
when we go to these uh like weird pet
stores I take my son to here in the
valley they'll have tarantulas and all
these snakes and my son goes dad I want
a snake I'm like you don't though I go
what do you do with it
what are you doing what are you think
you're gonna cuddle of that night you
think you put them in your bed there's
none of that buddy you might be able to
put on your arm and take pictures for
the gram which you don't have accounts
who gives a [ __ ] what do you do feed it
you wanna go you don't have to eat right
dinos the food like the fish are going
no buddy you see that cute little mouse
over there you'll see I go they eat
those and you have to dangle it and put
it in this right and it is very scary I
am Frozen but enjoy that I said or you
can shut your little stupid mouth and
I'll get you one of these cool fish kill
each other don't eat mice yes now uh
that's a reticulated python what what
should you know about the reticulated
python they are the poisonous they are
the the white people of snakes nope
there's the redheads of snakes no the
reticulated python is the largest snake
in North America
in the world not in the world not the
largest but the
white that's the widest but uh
roundest not the roundest
but that is it I don't know not the
biggest not the widest but uh slowest
longest no that's not true
the Anaconda is the biggest no no home
please Baba let me hold on the Anaconda
is the widest biggest ridiculous place
is the longest what is the longest lake
in the world
regulated python reticulated python
second longest snake in the world right
next to the Anaconda I don't think it
says
32 feet long whoa dude what do you do
what do you do you get eaten if you're a
small one here's my thing too that that
albino python that got out I [ __ ]
hate albino animals I don't like
anything I'm so mean I just don't [ __ ]
with it have you ever seen that bed I
don't touch anything
I don't I don't I don't like anything
albino well bring up the benefits
doing racism woke adds way before
anybody
n-e-t-o-n they were they were on crazy
shaving company clothing company
uh and take a look at this picture of
the United Colors the United Colors of
medicine this was my generation and they
were wild they were always always very
you know forward
just forward thinking about well see see
woke has a bad connotation like woke
doesn't mean like right look at that
though so you see that that was about
though that was in Sierra Leone where
they were cutting people's hands off
blood diamonds well and it was also yeah
40 seconds yeah okay so they were
amazing keep going though in Ivory
sentenced to death sentence to death
like all the death row inmates
they were badass [ __ ] HPI HP
HIV positive this was way before any of
the stuff 1993 yeah and we'd be like
whoa dude look at that white black
yellow is showing three hearts three
times
everybody is I feel like saying yellow
racism oh yeah but everybody had the
same heart look at this fear and
clothing in L.A look at that [ __ ] wow
that's what they did back in the day
they were ballsy [ __ ] that's
the Monk on fire so there's a picture of
a monk on fire I don't know
I'm sorry you get better eyes yeah what
is that what that's a woman with there's
a body over it with blood
and they're amazing man I don't know
what it is it doesn't show keep going
the red red to your head oh my God
1994 94. look at them they were there
let me get through this
we gotta definitely like not show some
of these things
let's keep going I want to show you
something oh
unhate unhate campaign what the [ __ ]
no there's a picture can you just bring
up albino United calls
me really
just look at this
this is a real picture this one yeah
right there right there
so that's that's a real picture in in uh
Africa of an albino girl oh she's being
being made fun of and cheered at by the
entire time they're making fun of her
she looks like well that's not a good
picture there's a whole thing where
they're all looking at her see how
they're looking at her kid oh man yeah
that's terrible that's what she had to
deal with that's terrible yeah and it's
horrible you know that's an idea of what
people what else you got Jen let's see
oh
this actually happened so a guy in
Florida
he slapped a horse's butt a police
horse's butt and got charged with the
assault yeah haven't you ever seen Half
Baked
butter Buttercup said cup butter cup
yeah misdemeanor from our boy they're
they're basically police officers you
can't disrespect a horse of the law and
he wasn't drunk or anything he was
slapping a horse in the ass no the thing
first of all you might get kicked yeah
that's what I'm saying those things are
scary but also yeah they are like like
dogs like displaced dogs and horses
they're just an extension of the police
officer you [ __ ] with them you're in
trouble dude you ever see how that horse
so would he get though that one male
charges battery there's that one
batteries trying to mount that female
horse you ever see that I'm talking
about Mr hands no I'm glad that Bale
horse trying to try to a male horse is
trying to mount a female horse and the
female horse goes it's cool
dies yeah that guy looks like a butt
slapper his name is Alicia Lalani I
thought honestly I thought I was gonna
be someone else but it was a this guy
yeah he looked good he's like God damn
it how embarrassing is that he's
probably little he's just like hey look
you're in jail what are you in for I
slapped the horse in the butt and I
slapped it real hard to try to if he was
buzzed he was drunk just having fun it
says 2 A.M yeah I think he went but they
know they gave him test though oh wow
dad's sober yeah sober
just maybe an [ __ ] trying to get the
horse just trying to be funny too maybe
I don't know some guy's like I dare you
to do that with that cop and then you
know he smack the horse and a horse but
also 27. The Last Story says someone
slapped that horse like well no hold on
South Korea lives better oh thank god
dude I was gonna move there God I was
gonna move there and then I found they
banded the sex with dolls
imported into the country yeah so they
got to be made in Korea no so there's no
real ban on it but the Customs would
always hold them like they would hold
like hundreds and thousands of haters
because there's something something with
the
they want to make sure the countries
looked at in a certain way so oh so they
don't stop a ton of sex dolls coming in
the country but then conservatives hey
South Korea who are you to judge when I
pump my baby exactly because it's
private it's private in your home it's
not hurting anyone yeah they're not
putting on the grams so now it's dolls
in the mouth so now it's lifted and they
returned a bunch oh thank God I guess
because I was on the on the fence one
kind of sex all that they won't allow in
though which we all agree with is
childlike
yeah exactly so that's we agree with the
play Devil's Advocate or should they so
these pedophiles get their rocks off on
a fake doll that's a damn good question
but very controversial but that's a good
question what do you think that's a very
important question like if you go to
rehab you walk out with a plastic
child everybody knows you'd rather have
somebody
having sex with a doll than a person but
everybody knows if your pedophile should
be put down like a dog right yeah we
agree on that yeah yeah
um last one the lady's eyes are cool
I'll keep going yeah last one someone
said this in it was a t fat cat army guy
but I don't remember who it is but it
says it literally it's the why it's
funny it says random Korean dude breaks
the world record but unofficially well I
would say random Korean dude he's
clearly not a random Korean I don't know
because he's not like famous a
weightlifter I don't know who is famous
but uh so this is him and I'm not sure
if we're gonna show the video he's in
him doing 800 pounds play the video for
with no uh audios looking at the hands
to make sure no one's hands are touching
seems pretty legit oh that looks legit
so that's 7.99 this is a bench press at
479. I don't know weights let's show you
guys okay but how much does he weigh no
idea so he's the 100 pound 100 110
kilogram weight class so what's that two
or something I'll look it up right now
after this so this is a 479 bench and
then the last one is a deadlift at 8 32.
damn
foreign
[Applause]
wow
so is that like insane nuts that's
insane dude no all right you know our
boy uh Lane Norton he's got the world
he's got world record for deadlift you
know that's my boy the Lane's done Rogen
a bunch he's a nutrition expert he
always takes out all the nutrition
claims he doesn't have the deadlift
record
uh he just won nationals I'll look it up
but he's 242 pounds this guy that's a
good guy Lane's only 185. Lane Norton he
didn't set the deadlift record Lane pay
for his weight 800 pounds oh that's not
even close Bubba the mountain did over a
thousand no I know but I'm saying for
his weight class maybe yeah which is
insane also natural
this is Lay Norton's personal best
deadlifts at 330 kilograms that'd be
like 600 something right
yeah squatters uh so that would be 720
27.
just we just won Gold for that
was 2019. yeah uh IPS World Records it
comes to get bounced what yeah for his
weight he's not a big guy yo he's
let's take a look he's a he's a PhD in
nutrition uh really smart guy how do you
not know brilliant is funny he's a
really good guy how would I know him be
he's a good friend so does he look
familiar no I've never seen that game in
my life yeah great guy he takes a [ __ ]
oh yeah but he's he's a dime piece but
he also takes on a whole bunch like
anytime somebody has a oh so the guy who
said Dana White he goes Dana he looked
at all the things and he goes you'll be
dead in 10 years and Lane was like
really let's take a look at the science
let's actually take a look at all this
well now I like this thing
that's snake oil snake oil
for a ride Lane takes Lane will look at
all that he's read all the stuff he's
got his PhD so he's read all the [ __ ]
stuff and he's like yeah I'm gonna take
a look
what science is it because if money was
a thing where you could just pay money
and the guy goes you're gonna die at 41
if you don't change how many people
would that help right he's like let's
take a look at the actual science all
right
yeah now you see his bodybuilding
pictures yeah he doesn't that's not
really that's so funny
it's bad that's him back in the day that
was way back he doesn't do that [ __ ]
anymore that's him younger yeah
yeah he's jacked yeah he's got crazy
good genetics man
that's bodybuilding
Almighty
that was it I think uh that guy Derek
from more place more dates he does do
these deep Dives on these people yeah
and some people actually give them his
blood tests or their blood tests I'm not
sure if Lane did that or not what
shut up about what just shut up nice oh
Maddie dude don't go
I'm messing Chin Chin Chin
played States more plates more dates I
love him he's great it's that's the
world we live in right we're all
suspected everybody when you see someone
that shred um in my head I go I don't
know all of us but chances are he's
probably all Maddie but we're so just
conditioned polluted with just [ __ ]
in my head I go ah I wouldn't bet on it
I want to see what would happen to you
if you actually did the kind of things
that those strong people were like like
competitive crossfitters I want to see
like the highest competitive crossfits I
think I should just stop making money in
income yeah but I'd like to dedicate my
life no I think you could do everything
you're doing oh no way no no there's no
way you have to train him
literally before Christmas I took uh
Christmas Eve off but I was working up
to Christmas Eve yeah my girl we're in
bed she goes it will you please stop and
take some days off here what time he
goes you don't see it because you see
yourself every day in the mirror you
look terrible she goes you're gonna die
yeah I said that to you this morning I
know I don't like the way you look well
this is I'm just bloated for it I feel
so much better I did need a break I've
worked 27 days in a row can't stop won't
stop whoever tells you that like don't
stop won't stop they're lying I was
forced to and it was not good yep you
need rest man
oh wow see Derek from place no dates
believes
oh I believe him yeah I I mean I believe
that this Lane guys picture on the left
when he was trying wait where's that
power lifting heart training PhD in
nutrition Sciences Elaine is a [ __ ]
smart [ __ ] and he also doesn't
look like freakishly jacked he looks
he's just got great genetics just a
great looking guy yeah yeah smart as
[ __ ] Lane will always tell you he goes
Lane will always tell you hey scroll
down to him uh this guy I'm not gonna
say this is Han
okay
oh interesting but where's durge and say
it here though right no I just pull the
slates more dates not on it no no so
there's just a random thing that's red
yeah I don't want to talk about
oh it's interesting I think we should
have them on yeah I I believe he's we'll
definitely that's that's the problem is
even me I've dude joke laubenstein Tim
Tebow I've been around some freaks Lance
Vickers people would pick out 100 if you
showed Joe klopfenstein up there what
like when I when I met him just when he
was walking around I've never seen
anything like it and everybody would be
like there's no [ __ ] words
100 natural that's right there
he was right there and I'm a
professional UFC fighter look at me next
to him oh dude he's such I look like a
turd he is such a [ __ ] freak his legs
too dude when I when I'm back same thing
when I went back home to Colorado
um
to to when my grandma passed away I went
to a game because he's a coach there now
and he freaking uh was I went to his
game his high school game he's on the
sidelines in shorts
it I I'm with his family hey can we
acknowledge how freak what a freaking
freak this kid is oh he's getting bigger
but not fat he's just so big yeah I'm
like oh yeah yeah I'm with his mom and
dad and his wife so Andre I'm like can
we please acknowledge how big he is
right now his legs for you to say that
he's you know me I don't give anybody
credit I don't care yeah in his shorts
like is this simply I've seen they're
obscene and I yo I notice how when
usually sit down like where's Joe at no
no you're like oh my God this is well
also the way his ass goes out and then
goes into his back oh no I told him I
told his mom I go he's a distraction for
this team is a distraction his ass is a
distraction as a straight distraction
his ass distraction yeah yeah cardi B on
the sidelines trying to coach up the
kids he had some crazy vertical he was
265 pounds six foot six oh he's every
bit of six six yeah yeah 37 inch
vertical sir 37 this article freak
around the 40 in a four five two or
something stupid four five well you know
he's a legit freak yeah all first team
all Big 12 like terrible diet just you
know worked hard and freak yeah so
there's people yeah Smart Guys there's
people like that so even though I'm
around that you know I've seen all night
of people do that
so even that and I've been around it and
then I see these guys like this in my
head first thing we're actually ah
there's no way yeah but it's my thing I
go older when it's a athlete I'll give
them benefit out sometimes unless it's
UFC but if other leagues I'll usually
give them back for the doubt
if they're in that Fitness World
right away nope
yeah it's just what you know
yeah and then I'll then just to say
they're on steroids isn't enough like
there's you know there's peptides and
all sorts of igf-1 and yeah HGH
all stuff that I look Donald Cerrone has
been very open about it and looks
fantastic he's 220. dude when he's on
fight campaign I'm like dude you're
jacked and he goes dude 10 grand a month
I'll kill you not choose my guy went I
would not spend 10 grand a month
it's a lot of money but it looks great
Jack City
someone said Cowboy you accidentally
grabbed Conor McGregor's water bottle
Derek Wolfe was a Bronco great but
swoleville you want to talk about freak
Derek Waltham freak play for the Broncos
with the d-tackle or DN for Cincinnati
the Bearcats freak that's him that's him
freak really well it's freak of all
freaks oh my Lord holy mother of God
well freak of all freaks who look he's
as big as his truck that's [ __ ] a
giant how big is he huge what in the
world who is he he played in the NFL for
a long time stud
great hair
just a giant
free Viking
complete free you know him
no uh six five two hundred four pounds
all right played for uh University of
Cincinnati played for the Broncos was
stud with the Broncos
um but my uh you know one of my close
friends strength condition coach Lauren
Landau who's still the coach for the
Broncos
I was like he's the biggest freak on
team it was Derek well I'm close oh
really and I didn't know him at the time
I knew he was good in college and then I
looked at him like holy [ __ ] he's like
complete freak dude
freak
so those guys are out there and he's all
Natty so [ __ ] off you know I uh I wanted
to bring in this this grip strength
tester for you why dude I I have it
and I'm not very strong
bother me yeah you need a device to do
that I thought I had strong hands don't
use my hands enough to say I have strong
hands no you don't Brian no no real
strong hands up there yeah they're real
strong hands you know what these hands
are made for
fish I'm a it's a falling just annoying
you're annoying me now I gotta get out
of here because I have 100 gallon tank
to attend to I have to pick it up yeah
I'm gonna put water in there okay and
get the water right yeah put the gravel
the coral yep and then put some
dangerous fish you would have liked me
yesterday I was at I had my show in
Venice it was last night yeah you called
me because I was doing sits around town
I knew you weren't gonna drive down the
rain I would have drove so I was on the
road a guy's out there and he's smoking
a vape and he's a giant man and I go
you're Simone he goes I am he and he was
gonna get a picture I go you can I shook
his hand and I and I you know man I go
well that's the biggest hand I've ever
felt the question what are you doing is
why I played football you know his
girlfriend said Planet UNLV which is Big
Time football right and good football
okay I don't know but just Mountain West
just bigger and stronger than everybody
in the room then then I there's a table
there's a guy like probably about 50
handsome kind of muscular guy and then
there's
Jack Armstrong All-American mustache
with a like a like a long sleeve shirt
with the biggest arms and chest but just
all put together did you [ __ ] all of
them or what yet and then another guy
another guy who's just got that triangle
matter yep another guy and I look at
them and I go guys what Navy SEAL
division are you guys in or the Navy
they start gigging giggling because
where the Navy are yeah they're frogmen
well of course you are well if you've
ever seen coolant hey Frogman and
winkman froggies
no frogs but all the girls all the women
who are in their 30s and sucked them off
all they were doing was looking at those
guys the way you would look at it hot
chicken well the way you would love
those guys no the girls were looking the
way you look at them yeah that's right
no no who the only person looking at
them harder with me yeah now Brian to
wrap the story up that I don't care
about these big guys at your show who
[ __ ] who okay give me the D okay well
because if nobody got there they were
attracted to me if nobody got their cup
yeah I don't care all right you're right
no one's pants came down no not even
yours
hey then look at me
but I don't care but I would have said I
would have said to my lady I would have
said you're more attracted to those guys
I know you got to give your lady up you
got to offer your lady out of respect
and also self-loathing they should do it
for me out of the fact me too I'm a
piece of [ __ ] I don't deserve you please
sir well you have no choice right
because they could kill you with their
bare hands I'd say hey frogs
they beat me at all the sports but I'm
funny
they might be funny
not bad Navy Seals are fun
seals are funny no no so actually though
I think the Navy Seals football players
because you're working teams good guys
like high accuses I social IQ yes
because you have to work with football
players oh I've never met a football
player that wasn't high social IQ level
I'll introduce you something yeah
there's some that yeah they just but
they're hella football players but they
don't they just there's some receivers
on the line though probably no the lines
you have they have no choice
mainly the skill positions be a little
bit of sociopath you can be a wide
receiver you can and as long as you
catch the ball you get the job done
their egos isn't it funny that a lot of
the wide receivers are that way biggest
egos yeah they're on island on their own
the biggest problem players sometimes
are wide receivers am I replaced
sometimes with every time okay every
time yeah actually if you look a thing
about the NFL yeah in the NFL it's not
the quarterbacks never ever the biggest
well Russell Wilson's a nightmare in
Denver yeah he has his own parking spot
in his own office okay he has more
toilets in his house that's what happens
when you give somebody that big a
contract but well they just fired the
head coach yeah but and your boy won a
bet with Uncle Jason I have a question
before we stop about football because
because Jay and my dad went to group
Texas you know we're from Denver Broncos
fans my dad goes uh before the Rams game
on uh Christmas day or it might have
been on Sunday but either way recently
my dad goes if the Broncos do this game
does coach get fired I go absolutely
special is a bad loss Diego nope don't
wait till the end of the year my dad
goes wanna bet
but I'll bet interview any amount of
money if they lose bad today he gets
fired by tonight my dad goes I'll take
that bet with you I agree he's gonna get
fired tonight Jay goes absolutely not
throwing away at the end of the year I
went guarantee gets fired they lose
whatever 50 to 7.
press conference literally that night
fired and I'm hoping they get Sean
Payton as a coach wow
wow or I think you have Deion Sanders
coach the Broncos and the club who do
you think is going to the Super Bowl
hold on
is it the Eagles
um 49ers
49ers are my Dark Horse with uh Purdy or
whatever the [ __ ] his name is the the Mr
Irrelevant because uh Garoppolo no
grandpa kiddos is tied in right uh
Grappler got hurt so they have the
backup oh right right they have the
backup uh Brock Purdy I think playing
out uh Iowa State shot Iowa State and uh
I think they could it could be like a a
cool story really if if Debo Samuel
comes back Nick Bosa who we love you
know that well well how about that
there's how about Dallas no I think
Niners beat Dallas they played better I
think Dallas could do a run but they
always [ __ ] themselves Dak just doesn't
play great in the playoffs Eagles will
be tough to beat yeah and then from the
from the uh AFC you're looking at I
think bills bills bills and Chiefs
and then you got Minnesota not a bad
team
FedEx guy just yelled FedEx
uh we're waiting for food yeah every all
problem players are almost always
[ __ ] wide receivers Divas because
their egos are so big and they don't
really have to play as a team
right out there again dude I hate to go
back to fish like fish dude just feed
them
stop using fish metaphors no he thinks
about fish all right kids have a great
[ __ ] is this our last show for the
New Years sir well I want to thank the
fans for 2022. yeah thanks for being
there for us because you're you're back
full year you're back right you know
before that thank you thank you thank
you hate my life yeah we held the fort
down and we always do Bubba yeah we're
slowly coming back buddy we're slowly
working our way back I don't know I
think the the whole point is in in
everything is you just don't keep doing
[ __ ] don't think it's about Jesus Christ
well it's about fish
all right we want to know keep your fish
I want you guys know in 2023 this shows
solely going to be about fish freshwater
fish fish tanks yeah the new show is
called fighter and the fish and it's
it's only if you have a 50 gallon plus
you can contribute okay it's got a huge
aquarium fighter and the fish we should
put another year down another fish tank
right here down another year down put a
fish tank right here with piranhas it's
actually a good idea and then when you
say something stupid like these dudes
that came to your show and there's no
I'll put your hand in it yeah electric
Yelp that'd be cool and I just pissed
and if the guests like how do I do like
not great put your hand in there I pull
a little bit so we have to wear diapers
oh that'd be cool all right kids happy
New Year enjoy the year go see Brian in
Boston Thursday sold out Friday Saturday
go see him things in San Diego might
drop comedy uh that's January 5th
through the 7th San Diego come see it be
a bunch of strong guys there guarantee
it uh Fort Wayne Indiana Summit Comedy
Club also known as stranger things Danny
of Florida is January 19th to 21st go
use cheese round for Brian
calenbryantown.com or fatkz.com my tour
day kicks off next week January 5th
that's next Thursday Friday Saturday CES
is in town so I'm gonna compete with all
those Tech nerds so come get some Wise
Guys Las Vegas for the locals one of my
favorite clubs My Boy Keith who owns
Wise Guys in Salt Lake City runs that
place so is Pauly Shore but uh Las Vegas
I think Josh Wolf's going to make a
special appearance with me out there
because he lives in Vegas love Josh
absolutely adore Josh love shout out to
Josh wolfy uh so that's next week next
Thursday Friday Saturday first tour date
2023 the new year come get some let's
sell it out Wise Guys Las Vegas then
January 20th through 21st that's just
two shows Friday two shows Saturday
Tampa Florida Tampa Improv I'm in
Springfield Missouri never been have no
idea where it's at Naples Florida I'm
there February 16th to 18th it's gonna
be an older white crowd and we're gonna
talk about you guys uh rating the
capital uh Bakersfield California
February 23rd one night only and then a
bunch of other tour dates thinkboy.com
for that thick nectar gear everything
tour dates go get some Happy New Years
guys thanks for Trucking along with us
especially loyal people out there truck
along with us like subscribe 2023 is
gonna be a good year man we all have fun
guests coming up and
just keep on keeping on buddy you're
right buddy love you guys see you next
year get it see you next year and thank
you go fish go fish not the Dolphins we
love you I love all the fans and if you
don't think about fish damn your boy I'm
looking for a crazy aggressive
freshwater fish